[Applaudissements]
merci à vous jeens de ma ville vous qui
l'avez fait à mon goût si je m'y sens le
cœur tranquille c'est toujours un peu
grâce à
vous merci pour tout ce que je trouve
aux quatre coins de mon Paris pour cette
galerie du Louvre où la Joconde me
sourit pour la fraîcheur de Notre Dame
où V François Villon pour séduire une
jolie dame qui logeait près du petit
pont merci Monsieur Mansard et
Jose de la part de M Pinon vous offrir
un bouquet de rose pour sa
mansarde et sa
chanson merci Jean-Baptiste
pour les beau soirs que je vous dois
rideau de velour et
lumière tout comme à versaill
autrefis merci Monsieur le roi de France
Louis Charles Henri de votre nom le
chiffre n'a plus
d'importance et pour le
16e
pardon merci pour toutes ces richesses
dont je rends grâce à ma
façon Paris qui valut une
messe peut bien
valoir une
[Musique]
chanson